well the man who our racist president
viciously insulted by calling him his
boy
biden's senior advisor cedric richmond
he got his own back this morning watch
what is the philosophy of the president
well we will consult with congress
you nailed it cedric what's the
president's philosophy oh let me check
with congress i'll get back to you once
i've been told what biden stands for by
pelosi or bernie or pramila jayapal or
aoc or ilhanom or whoever it is who's in
charge of the president's philosophy
these days
here's how i put it last week
that's why it's all falling apart
biden is nothing
nothing but an utterly mediocre machine
politician surrounded by amateurs hacks
and juvenile leftists
little did i imagine that biden's own
senior advisor would confirm my critique
so precisely within the week
whatever you think of bernie sanders
ideas when you watch him speak you see
blazing consistent conviction about what
he wants to achieve when you watch biden
speak you see
nothing on friday he limped up to
capitol hill to break the deadlock on
passing his agenda
he didn't break the deadlock he just
broke his promises
he told america he'd be a moderate a
centrist that would unite the country he
can't even unite his party
except in their total contempt for him
he is one democrat member of congress
stephanie murphy
i'm not clear why he came up to the hill
i'm not clear why he goes anywhere
except back to delaware
for over a year now before the 2020
election since the inauguration i've
argued that the central defining feature
of joe biden the foundational defect
that determines all the other defects is
that he is a machine politician
with no beliefs or convictions or
principles someone who for nearly 50
years in politics has done whatever is
expedient to advance his own career
someone who's pushed around by his
donors by the unions by whoever holds
the power in his party and that's why at
this moment in this democratic party as
i've said over and over again biden is
the feeble puppet of the far left
any possible doubt about that was
removed this week every serious
commentator has characterized the events
of the past few days in the same way a
massive victory for the progressives and
humiliating defeat for the moderates a
defeat for biden of course but also a
defeat for pelosi the master legislator
forced by the left to pull her own
deadline twice
and then still fail to pass the bill she
promised would be law by now instead
it's going to be halloween apparently
that's a new deadline halloween how
appropriate
already their giant spending bill has
shrunk by a billion and a half instead
of 3.5 trillion the new number is
somewhere in between 1.9 trillion and
2.3 trillion we're told oh is that all
remember this is on top of the six
trillion they've already spent bailing
out their own stupid lockdowns and on
top of the 1.2 trillion they want to
spend on infrastructure just a couple of
trillions somewhere between 1.9 and 2.3
in the real world that's somewhere
between albania and venezuela
of course they're trying to pretend
the real cost is zero that's their new
insanely dishonest talking point the
real cost is zero because it's all paid
for yeah it's all paid for by raising
taxes and the people who are going to
pay the taxes as they always do
are the middle class the small business
owners democrats claim they'll cut taxes
on working families but what they
actually mean
is raising taxes on working families and
giving some of it back
in welfare payments to make them
dependent on the government forever
to her great credit arizona's democrat
senator kirsten cinema is objecting to
these tax increases she says the trump
tax cuts should stay of course they
should
they helped create the strongest economy
in american history historically low
unemployment a blue collar boom with
earnings rising fastest for the lowest
paid and for the crime of wanting to
keep those gains
senator cinema is trashed by her own
party in the media and there we were
thinking they loved a maverick senator
from arizona who threatens to sink
flagship legislation
joe manchin meanwhile objects to the
spending part and he got to the heart of
it on thursday
i cannot accept our economy or basically
our society moving towards an
entitlement mentality
and that in fact gets to the central
argument about the impact of what
they're cooking up in congress
and about its very legitimacy
bernie in the left are crystal clear
about what they want to do they want a
political revolution they want to turn
america into a european style welfare
state with a metastasizing federal
government bureaucracy controlling every
aspect of every american's life they're
open about that so let's take them at
their word but let's also point out that
it's not just un-american it is
anti-american
america was founded on the idea of
decentralized power power in people's
hands no one should be over mighty not
the president not the congress not the
federal government not the bureaucracy
checks and balances separation of powers
this is the very essence of america and
the democrats want to overturn it
as a new citizen of this country perhaps
my reverence for the constitution is
naive
but we have something called the 10th
amendment the powers not delegated to
the united states by the constitution
nor prohibited by it to the states are
reserved to the states respectively or
to the people
child care family leave community
college all the rest of it i'm not
against these things but they are
matters for state government local
government neighborhoods individuals and
families that's the american way
instead the democrats want us to be like
europe well look what happened in europe
when the arrogant euro maniacs and
complacent bureaucrats pushed too far
with their endless interference and
dogmatic centralization nations fought
back
brexit won't be the last
i've seen it firsthand the technocratic
zealots they talk about lifting people
up and leveling the playing field and
creating common standards but in the end
it is all about imposing their ideology
on everyone else
and there comes a point where people say
no we have had enough
these reckless democrats are putting the
very integrity of america at risk
with this brazen attempt at an
unprecedented centralization of power
and usurpation of the constitutionally
protected rights of individuals and
states
will anyone stand up and challenge the
constitutionality of the democrats giant
government centralization scheme
and that brings us to the second
fundamental objection
where is the political legitimacy for
this revolution they keep telling us
it's biden's agenda no it's not
he never talked about this kind of
transformation of the country with this
kind of price tag he ran as a moderate
as a centrist
this is not build back better it's
billed bernie's blueprint which would be
fine if bernie had won the election but
he didn't he didn't even win the primary
he was rejected by the majority of
democrats let alone the country
biden's puffed up ego and boundless
vanity have led him to compare himself
to fdr with a new deal and lyndon
johnson with the great society
but as peggy noonan pointed out this
weekend
his party won the house would only buy a
handful of seats the senate's 50 50. the
countries closely split mr biden's
governing margin is precarious yet his
economic proposals are sweeping as if it
won the great society mandate of 1964
lyndon johnson's landslide was huge
61
to barry goldwater's 38.5 johnson came
in with 68 democratic senators and a 295
140 house majority
this entire shambles on capitol hill
with more to come in the months ahead it
is all in pursuit of a program that is
unconstitutional
and illegitimate and we need to say so
clearly
tell us what you think at steve hilton x
and at nextrev fnc and share this
message
when we post it
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now